[Música]
bienvenidos al enlace andino en esta
edición de este lima perú hoy hablaremos
sobre el ex presidente alberto fujimori
y el caso de las mujeres esterilizadas
que ya llevan más de dos décadas miles
de víctimas reclama justicia y exigen
que el exgobernante sea juzgado
[Música]
también abordaremos la crisis política
en la que se encuentra el actual
gobierno del presidente pedro castillo y
el congreso confrontación de ambos
frentes posee los que exigen vacancia
presidencial por un lado y cierran el
parlamento por otro alimentan la
atención mientras la población vive en
la incertidumbre y la economía se
mantiene estancada
finalmente conoceremos el drama que
padecen líderes así líderes indígenas
del medio ambiente quienes reclaman al
estado peruano articular políticas
públicas para proteger a los pueblos
originarios que viven amenazados por
actividades extractivas minería ilegal y
el narcotráfico que denuncian ponen en
peligro los territorios ancestrales las
fuentes de agua la flora y la fauna
la justicia peruana se toma su tiempo
para decidir se inicia el juicio al ex
presidente alberto fujimori por el caso
de las mujeres esterilizadas sin
importar que las víctimas llevan 20 años
exigiendo justicia cnj que la fiscalía
formalizó denuncia penal contra el
exmandatario y tres ex ministros de
salud de su gobierno
las denuncias reportan que más de 270
mil mujeres y alrededor de 24.000
hombres habrían sido esterilizados
contra su voluntad argumentando la
ejecución de un programa de
planificación familiar para combatir la
pobreza mujeres indígenas y de zonas
rurales fueron sometidas a cirugías
forzadas que les dejó serias secuelas y
muertes en algunos casos el tema fue
archivado en tres oportunidades y en
otras tres fue reabierto la actual
audiencia de control de acusación se
inició en marzo de 2021 y en lo que va
del año no se toma una decisión para
abrir proceso a fujimori las víctimas
han protestado innumerables veces en las
calles por la desatención de la justicia
y de cinco gobiernos
las cosas negativas uno dice que te
decaen pero en nuestro caso nos da más
fuerza y a mí particularmente porque
pienso a seguir adelante estoy con mis
compañeras del limay de provincia con
fuerza para seguir adelante no nos vamos
a decaer hemos dicho las
esterilizaciones forzadas ya nunca más y
esterilizaciones forzadas vaya ahora no
vamos a dejar que sigan primando a la
corrupción que ha habido durante más de
25 años la lentitud de la justicia ha
dado pie a diversas suspicacias le
preguntamos a un especialista en
derechos humanos si consideraba que el
caso iba a quedar impune y eso fue lo
que nos dijo
fujimori tiene que pagar los delitos
cometidos y por eso me parece que se
hizo bien cuando se
denunció a alberto fujimori y cuando se
comprendió alberto fujimori en la en la
investigación y me parece que el mérito
haber encontrado
evidencias de su intervención como autor
mediato de este delito es que el
ministerio público formula una industria
naturaleza y me parece que los cargos
que se ha hecho fujimori en este caso
son cargos no solamente sólidos sino que
si encuentran evidencias suficientes de
la existencia de políticas alentadas
desde la presidencia de la república que
tuvieron como resultado los crímenes que
éste se perpetraron en diversas regiones
del perú no no solamente en lima muchos
pensaron que las elecciones de junio
pasado en perú traerían estabilidad al
país se equivocaron el izquierdista
pedro castillo fue electo presidente y
eso impulsó más la polarización en esta
nación donde la derecha de grupos
económicos no aceptan que un profesor
provincia no los haya derrotado
pedro castillo lleva casi 100 días en el
poder y no puede sacar al perú de la
recesión económica en que se encuentra
tampoco ha impulsado programas sociales
para sus electores la designación de
cuestionados personajes como ministros
encendió el enfrentamiento con el
congreso castillo cambió al gabinete
ministerial esto habría un conflicto con
sus socios de perú libre quienes lo
acusan de traidor por alejar el gobierno
a los aliados y dejarse intimidar la
oposición que controla el poder
legislativo modificó la constitución y
eliminó la norma que le permitía cerrar
el congreso pedro castillo se encuentra
vulnerable ante sus rivales quienes
anuncian que tarde o temprano será
sometido un proceso de vacancia
presidencial o impide ahora conozcamos
la realidad de defensoras y defensores
del medio ambiente de diversas regiones
del perú los indígenas se trasladaron a
lima para denunciar que son perseguidos
encarcelados llevados a juicio y hasta
asesinados por defender sus territorios
ancestrales y la biodiversidad
se sienten indignados porque seis
líderes ambientales fueron asesinados
durante el año pasado en plena pandemia
del cob y 19 acusan al estado peruano de
haberlos abandonado siendo aliados
estratégicos para la protección del
medio ambiente exigen que se les
reconozca como actores imprescindibles
en la lucha por el cambio climático
nosotros defendemos nuestras aguas
nuestros ríos nuestra cultura
y que no seamos
criminalizados cuando hacemos protesta
cuando exigimos al estado que nos cumpla
que los que nos cumplan los acuerdos o
que nos que nos ayuden o
el gobierno se comprometió a implementar
mecanismos para protegerlos y no
criminalizar sus protestas gracias por
acompañarnos en esta emisión del ac
andino desde lima perú les invitamos a
que nos envíen sus sugerencias sobre
temas que les gustaría ver en nuestro
programa sigan disfrutando de la
programación de france 24 en español y
hasta pronto